welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and we just got a brand new trailer
for the snyder cut of justice league
coming to hbo max this looks like zack
snyder dropped it a little early
because it leaked in warner's just like
just drop it out they know how to just
release things apparently we've been
seeing little teases of what's to come
in this trailer so i'm very excited to
take a look at it i'm gonna react to it
here and then talk about it for a little
bit and then tomorrow is gonna be my
shot by shot breakdown of all the easter
eggs hidden in this so if i don't cover
stuff in this video it just means i
haven't gotten there yet so
here we go
[Music]
shockwave
[Music]
the
[Music]
but in the dark
among the stars
oh my god is dead
looks good i had a dream
almost like a premonition
[Music]
i need warriors i'm building an alliance
to defend ourselves
how do you know your team's strong
enough
if you can't bring down the charging
bush then don't wave the red cape
[Music]
and even if it takes you the rest of
your life
find out what that reason is
he said the age of heroes would never
come again
[Music]
love that shot of their bro it has to
it has to
where is he we live in a society
it's a distant memory isn't that right
batman
i'm sorry i'm not just saying we live
okay all right uh no no
um well okay in a way
okay okay no no no
no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no
no person's out of the gate we live in a
society i think zack snyder jerry letter
they got to be
aware of the meme around this we live in
a society where
people respect each other we live in a
society where
the president when he's called out
conceits
i mean leave it to this version of the
joker he's swapped out the damage tattoo
for we live in a society this joker was
designed
to be a reaction to all the kind of pop
culture
joker it takes he's got all the tattoos
he's got like the weird teeth
he's kind of self-aware in a weird way
some of the other jokers aren't now i
didn't detect uh much irony in jared
leto's delivery there but
the line itself it is kind of perfect
for a joker to
say we live in a society that lets that
honor and i also
love this because i don't really
remember seeing this meme until like the
past couple years the first time i
remember seeing it
ironically to make fun of the we live in
a society edge lord [ __ ] was with
the joaquin phoenix joker so i feel like
this must be something that zack snyder
added
after the fact this wasn't something
that was there originally so
personally i love that this was added
back in and since i've been spending all
my time staring at these beautiful
specimens i have been trying to eat
better which means trying to avoid extra
sugar and gluten and lots of other stuff
but that's what i cannot eat what is
left that i can't eat well my friends
it's magic spoon cereal
it's got no junk in it but it tastes
really good it's almost like
too good for how healthy it is
each serving is only 140 calories with
zero sugar
14 grams of protein and only four net
grams of carbs it's keto friendly and
gluten free
grain free low carb and gmo free i
really love this flavor this is
peanut butter it's so good it's like the
classic peanut butter cereal that you
ate as a kid i feel like i'm a little
boy again but i'm eating cereal that
like
you know big boys grown adults should
eat so that it doesn't destroy you
magic spoon's got great flavors like the
original cocoa fruity and frosted and
they got other great flavors like
cinnamon uh blueberry
peanut butter and magic spoon drops new
limited edition flavors
all the time click the link below to get
some magic spoon cereal today you can
build your very own variety box and use
my code
new rockstars for five dollars off you
can choose from the best-selling cocoa
fruity frosted and peanut butter flavors
plus
awesome other flavors including
blueberry and cinnamon so many of you
have asked about this and now is the
first time magic spoon has ever released
this new option to build your very own
custom box
where you can build it however you want
so don't wait and magic spoon is so
confident in their product it is packed
with a 100
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any reason they'll refund your
money no questions asked just click that
link below use the code new rockstars
for five dollars off or go to
magicspoon.com
new rockstars to save five dollars off
your order today so again i'm gonna go
back through this shot by shot for the
breakdown just a couple things that
stood out to me right now i love how
this uh
this vocal shock wave was added to
superman's dying moments i was wondering
why we were revisiting that and now it
seems clear that it was kal-el's scream
is dying scream that
maybe oh woke those three mother boxes
on earth and that's what kind of leads
to that bell being rung
right that's what calls dark side that's
the dinner bell i mean what's cool about
looking at a trailer like this is there
aren't a ton of surprises other than uh
jared leto joker showing back up like we
know what the general plot of this movie
is gonna be
we understand that i just think now
we're looking at it for what are the
little fixes zack snyder made to just
make this look a lot better
and to make this a more coherent story
and i
gotta say i mean steppenwolf looks
[ __ ] sick this
scaly sharp looking armor is just
really cool looking it's definitely a
step up from the weird kilt
that we didn't had in there before now
what i'm loving from this it looks like
cyborg
is there in the uh the nightmare
post-apocalyptic future
that is really cool before it was you
know it just seemed like bruce was there
and everyone else might have been dead
but of course cyborg would be there that
guy can withstand anything
so even though he won't be in the flash
movie i love that snyder seems to be
compensating for that and putting him
more
in this movie i hope this is really a
cyborg movie yeah
and i gotta hand it to the trailer
editing here that if you can't bring
down the charging bull don't wave the
red cape at it synced with uh
steppenwolf with his horns charging at
him then synced with superman's red cape
in the hologram just kind of a nice
little matador sequence there
uh we get some shots of the dark side
throne room i love how the light is just
kind of streaming in through these
marble columns with you can see the
the wreckage of the city behind them
with those pillars of fire
now this isn't ancient earth this is
post-apocalyptic
right i mean there's skyscrapers back
there that have been wrecked this isn't
like
reformed wayne manor is it i mean would
dark side to sod and hagra all be there
anyway i just love seeing these three i
always really like zack snyder's design
of a kryptonian production design it
really does have a good like
otherworldly feel to it a mix of biology
and reproductive imagery but with like
this weird dirty techno grunge aesthetic
and you see that kind of reflected in
the apocalypse culture as well
there's almost a sense of spirituality
and religion that's being suggested here
uh i'm loving this shot of black suit
superman in action
it looks like we're getting a flight
sequence 2.0 the fist with the the rocks
floating up
i cannot wait to see that and then
circling back to uh jared leto here in
the post-apocalyptic nightmare
and again it looks like cyborg is like
bruce's right-hand man there i think
that's [ __ ] great
now leto is wearing his swat gear is
this a leftover
gear that he had when he broke out
harley quinn from the prison at the end
of suicide squad
he looks like he's wearing that weird
apron get up that he was wearing in the
photo zack snyder shared
underneath it yeah i don't know where
the tattoos went looking at his face
it looks like there is some scarring on
his cheek like maybe he
is using more cakey makeup to cover what
was there
but those cuts look like fresh and
whatever the makeup was
and the hair isn't just dark the light
kind of flashing through it shows that
the hair is just like a dark green
yeah there is more of a kind of tragic
clown take on this version of the joker
right maybe it's just the natural shape
of letto's face
but it doesn't have that kind of manic
goofball energy that he had in suicide
squad i am excited to see like a
different take like
this is a more world weary joker snyder
described him what has he been through
what does he mean that the world used to
have honor
yeah his voice is still [ __ ] weird
but this idea of we live in a society
where honor's a distant memory
did joker ever really have honor that
wasn't really
his whole rule his mo but i don't know
maybe jared leto's take on the joker
the fact that he's in a nightclub he's
more of a gangster you could say there
was a bit of honor there was more of a
code to him
or maybe you could be just saying like
honor is a distant memory and this is
the world i have always lived in and
welcome to my world now this is the
madness that he's always dreamed of but
never thought would actually happen he's
kind of like the dog who eventually
caught the car
and doesn't know what to do with it he
just feels kind of useless those are my
initial thoughts let me know what you
thought of this trailer i am excited to
go back through it shot by shot because
clearly snyder put a lot of love into
each of these images
and i kind of want to find everything
that he changed and everything he put in
there so that breakdown is coming out
tomorrow on the channel
keep an eye out for it of course new
rockstars will be doing a breakdown of
this
massive snyder cut when it releases on
march 18th may take us a couple days to
break this down though four hours of
something that's gonna be a lot of
re-watches and research
you can join this nerdy conversation on
new rockstar's official discord channel
by becoming a patron at patreon.com new
rockstars another way you can support us
is checking out one of our merch options
at nurseriesmerch.com be sure to
subscribe to new rockstars here on
youtube follow me at ea bots follow me
rockstars and social media and i'll see
you next time
society dwellers
[Music]
you